depuis son retour des jeux olympiques
thomas baruch vite un parcours du
combattant
victime d'une fracture de fatigue sur
une cote à la reprise de l'entraînement
au mois d'octobre
il écope ensuite d'une tendinite après
six semaines d'arrêt autant dire que le
rameur versaillais et en manque de
repères je pense que cette blessure elle
vient de l'accumulation fatigue et
stress de toute l'année dernière parce
que c'est pas que les jeux la
préparation des jeux elle a commencé en
octobre 2011 et on n'a pas arrêté de
toute la saison jusqu'aux jeux ça s'est
un peu calmé
thomas baroque retrouve enfin la
compétition championnats de france
indoor il ya quelques semaines ils se
rassurent et décroche une médaille de
bronze à 6 secondes de son meilleur
temps en six minutes 19 mai pour faire
partie de l'équipe de france thomas
dépend aussi de son coéquipier nicolas
mouton actuellement blessé lui aussi aux
épaules c'est un peu difficile d'avoir
des objectifs sur
les championnats de france parce que
parce qu'on a pas d'entraînement
ensemble donc on sait pas encore où on
en est on sait pas exactement
physiquement où on en est tous les deux
parce que forcément
les arrêts pour blessure c'est pas ce
qu'est un pas que ça peut avoir
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'objectif seul objectif est de faire
une performance suffisante pour être
sélectionné en équipe de france et
ensuite
ensuite on verra l'équipage olympique a
jusqu'à mi mai pour décrocher sa
sélection pour les championnats d'europe
en espagne
en attendant l'ingénieur s'adapte à sa
nouvelle notoriété
ici au club auprès des jeunes
visiblement c'est un effet ouais en fait
ils viennent pas me voir parce que je
pense qu'ils sont un peu impressionnés
mais partout craeynest ossements dont
évidemment et je vois dans leur duel
dans le comportement quand il les croise
que
voilà il ça leur fait un bond lié